when you decide to opt for an mba
program the first big step would be to
get a high gmat score
this is because your admission into the
top p schools depends on your gmat score
so in this video we will reflect on all
the essential information you need to
know about this crucial yet dreaded test
but before we begin make sure to
subscribe to our channel and hit the
bell icon to never miss an update from
simplylearn gmat is the acronym for
graduate management admission test the
purpose of this test is to measure your
aptitude for management education
this test is an adaptive computer
assessment which means that the degree
of difficulty for each question will
depend on how you performed in the
previous questions
gmat grades are typically valid for five
years and the examination cost is 250 us
dollars
this exam can be attempted five times a
year and totally eight times throughout
your lifetime
the graduate management admission
council administers this examination
thus these scores are accepted by a
large number of universities across the
globe there are almost 7 000 programs at
approximately 2 300 b schools that
accept gmat scores for mba mim and other
management related programs
it is crucial for you to ace gmat test
since a high gmat score will not only
get you into your dream management
program and institution but it can also
enhance your chances of getting good
scholarships
having said that let's discuss the gmat
exam format
gmat takes three hours and seven minutes
to solve if you take no breaks in
between the sections however gmat
permits you to take two eight minute
breaks between the quant verbal and
integrated reasoning sections
this test assesses your ability to
perform in typical managerial roles if
you think what aptitude and verbal
skills have to do with it then think
about this
a manager is expected to be able to
manage two things people and numbers and
what better way to do it than to put
your aptitude and linguistic skills to
the test
gmat will test you in overall four
sections
integrated reasoning quantitative
analysis
verbal reasoning and analytical writing
assessment or awa
in the awa section you will have to
determine the reasoning behind the
provided argument and write a critique
of it including appropriate examples and
explanations
the ir section is designed to test your
analytical skills to solve complex
problems
here you will be provided with data in
various forms
by processing and extracting relevant
data you will be able to choose the
right answers for questions under this
section
the next section is verbal reasoning
in this section you will come across
reading comprehension critical reasoning
and sentence correction questions
your grammatical and linguistic
knowledge will be tested thoroughly in
this section
the last and fourth section of gmat is
quantitative ability
this section will put your mathematical
skills to test
most of the time the more thought of
having to deal with mathematics causes
us to despair but don't let this disturb
you as the mathematics involved in gmat
is what you have learnt at your high
school stage you just need to be clear
on the basics and then the rest is all
about implementing the skills you've
learned
this section has 31 questions and you'll
have two minutes to answer each of these
questions this portion of quants is
further split into three sections
arithmetic algebra and geometry
number theory percentage fractions
simple and compound interest set theory
rational and proportion speed time and
distance mixture and allegations
probability are all covered in the
arithmetic section
algebra contains sub-topics such as
permutations and combinations quadratic
equations
inequalities and basic statistics and
also algebraic expressions
and the geometry section deals with
topics such as quadrilaterals cylinders
coordinate geometry trigonometry and
solid shapes
all of the above mentioned topics must
have been covered in your high schools
right hence you will only need plenty of
practice to get a perfect score in this
section of gmat
the verbal and quantitative sections
contribute to the total score of 800.
each of these sessions is assessed on a
scale of 6 to 51 points while the
overall result is graded on a scale of
200 to 800 marks
the remaining two components awa and
integrated reasoning receive their
independent scores the next question we
have is
when and how to attempt the gmat test
you can take the gmat at more than 700
test centers across the globe you will
have to identify the closest test center
to your region and register the details
along with the date and time
many students delay it till a few months
before the application deadline
that's a terrible idea
to be on the safer side take at least
one year prior to your application date
that way you'll have plenty of time to
retake it if needed now the last topic
we have for this discussion is how to
prepare for gmat when it comes to gmat
preparation you have a number of
alternatives there are several coaching
institutions that can equip you to
perform to your full potential in the
gmat exam
these offliner online coaching crash
courses equipped with mock tests doubt
solving sessions and post entrance
assistance can undoubtedly help you
create your own strategy to get into
your dream management program
however self-study is the most cost
effective and adaptable method of
preparation
there are a plethora of kojima books
available to assist you in covering
everything from fundamentals to the
advanced topics the best gmat book that
you can refer to is the gmat official
guide
the graduate management admission
council publishes it on a yearly basis
by brushing up the understanding of
basic concepts and practicing over
multiple problems
you can definitely accomplish a good
gmat score
the average time necessity to complete
gmat study is about 3 months
of course a lot will rely on how quickly
you can learn the fundamentals and the
mode of study you choose for preparation
that's all we have for today i wish you
all the very best for your gmat test
thank you for watching this video and
stay tuned for more from simplylearn
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here